- The day before things got really crazy,
I went to target to get supplies and stuff
and while I was there I was
like "I should get legos."
I mean obviously. So I - okay.
- (Laughs)
- No no no no no. Okay, so number one,
this is kind of cool hang on.
I got
- Oh my god did you
make something awesome?
- No way!
- What?
- Yeah. Its not finished
but that R2-D2.
- Are you full of crap
right now? You did that?
- Yep.
- The Millennium Falcon.
- You guys, its amazing.
- Nicely done.
- Yeah.
- Okay okay okay but I'm in
like the Lego isle at Target
and I swear to God this is true,
this is not something that
got sent to me, or anything.
And I, hold please.
- (Laughs) I understand
what's happening right now.
- I bought trolls.
- (Laughs) Wait, wait.
- I bought them, from Target.
I swear to God I was like
- Who checked you out like
did you just by yourself?
- Don't get recognized in
the checkout line 'cause
how lame am I but I'm like I'm
just buying the merchandise
for myself. Look, look,
its her bed. Uh what?
- (Laughs)
- Which is the best part because
you don't have kids right?
This is just you hanging
out with your (laughs)
- This is me hanging out
and being a winner Kelly.
- Yeah.
- You're being supportive of art.
- Obviously.
- That's amazing, I just
love the person that
probably checked you out.
- Huh?
- Did no one recognize you?
- No. Even if the cashier
recognized me I swear to God
they would probably be like
"No I mean it looks like her
but it can't be her because of quarantine.
She wouldn't be buying her own merchandise
like an actual cereal killer.
- (Laughs) Oh God.